my one of my favorite Sundance memories
and I'm sorry for putting this in the
internet was Einstein bagels in Park
City I was sitting there I think you've
done an interview yes and I was like
walking over to just find a seat to eat
and he's sitting there practicing lines
for you were thinking about there was a
movie you were gonna do in Providence I
think where you were playing someone in
death row or I forget what the
conviction may be yeah yeah but I'm
gonna tie this together and he told me
how he listens to people talking and
that's how he picks up accents which
leads me to this movie because I heard
you were listening a lot to CP yes we
were both listening to an and CP quite a
bit and watching interviews yeah right
we had dialect coaches who were very
good very good dialect coaches cuz I had
to make sure that my register didn't go
back up I'm up here and hands down here
you know she talks her voice is a little
lower so I couldn't I couldn't kick stay
up here to write her I needed someone to
watch me cuz there were times when I
would get you know passionate and I get
this is really good yeah she helped me
out a few times too um one of the things
that I was very impressed with is a lot
of people you transform yourself in this
movie you physically the way you look
and you know some people might find you
might not want to do that for the role
they might want to make themselves look
a little better if you will and I think
you did such a brilliant job with the
what you did to look like an was there
any hesitation when you were gonna do
that or talk a little bit about wanting
to transform yourself I I loved
characters that take me outside of
myself I don't when it's time to become
a character taraji has to go away
it ain't about taraji and her vanity
it's about the truth of this character I
remember when I first went to try on my
fat suit and they had these nice perky
boobs and I said that's not gonna
transform the way I move like I need to
move differently and right now this suit
is too heavy I mean too light and I said
this woman had big boobs they're missing
like hey call Tyler Perry and ask for
asked him who made my dears boobs cuz I
need those and they they were blown away
coming to see that new one cos he's good
funny costuming they didn't they didn't
expect me to come in ready to surrender
all of my vanity they thought that they
were doing me a service by good I said
that's not who this woman is
so they had to revamp the whole suit and
then when I put it on and I said see now
I'm walking like this and I'm talking
you know I'm walking a different way
anyway Oh oh my god we just didn't know
it you would go there I was like have
you not been paying attention so my
cover I have to tell you something yo a
lot of people might not be willing to do
this that's what they say you know it's
like it's but that's one of the reasons
why I thought both of you did such a
tremendous job in this movie because I
bought into what I was seeing on screen
it felt real yeah you know it it's it's
such a incredible story
you can't it looks it you think it's
like a Hollywood made-up thing but all
of this really happened talk a little
bit about being being honest to what
really happened but the fact that you're
also making a movie so you want to be
careful but you're trying to entertain
it's one of those kind of things and you
can't fit everything in there you know
it was a two hour movie so many things
happen these people you can only do so
much in a two hour movie and and not
only that like wait go to ask the
question again I had such a great answer
basically we calibrate right I was gonna
say it's basically like balancing fact
and fiction and also but you know these
are real people and you you want to be
honest to what really happened what I
found fascinating about is that we
didn't have to Hollywood eyes the story
because just reading it seems fake
already it was like oh my god but then
when you do research and you know this
stuff really actually happened her
flipping that man around and hitting him
in the head with the phone all that is
true none of that we like you know
embellished on when that actually
happened so I think everyone involved we
were interested in telling the truth it
wasn't about a Hollywood moment it was
about a moment in history that actually
happened that we are actually seeing
happen again now and in 2019 and so that
the importance of the film wasn't about
making a Hollywood movie you know we
didn't care about a Hollywood film we
wanted a film that is going to impact
lives and change thoughts and
perceptions one of the things that I
think a lot of people won't realize when
they're watching it is you made this
entire film in 29 days Robin told me
that you were lucky to get three takes
sometimes talk a little bit about do you
enjoy that kind of back against the wall
filmmaking knowing you have a limited
time limited budget or are you a little
bit more in your head because you're
like oh my god I only have I got to get
it on the first take I like to be do it
and go home I'm a one-take I like one
takes especially your channels yeah I
was just gonna say that especially with
emotional stuff yeah yeah you don't want
to lay on those emotions to a drange
it's a lot if you give so much of
yourself as exhausting it can wear on
your spirit you know so I'm usually like
are we set up everything's good you all
got it cuz when I give it to you don't
expect it again that's how I work I
think that's true especially with
emotional season these days yeah yeah
that's kind of how you got to work these
days that's different than the 70s and I
think they did a lot more takes back
then I think it's you got to come in
sort of loaded for bear you know and
it's uh yeah it's intense yeah I'd like
to get in and get out one of the things
this is Robin's feature debut
although Robin has been producing for a
while are you more excited to work with
a full first-time filmmaker like this or
are you a little bit more nervous
because you never really I mean first
film you know what I mean I think what
they what they first-time directors lack
in experience they can make up for in
enthusiasm and passion you know and
certainly because Robin has been on a
set before you know he knows how film
sets run and that influenced him a lot
you know I've never I'm always about
giving people chances because I wouldn't
be where I am if someone didn't take a
chance on me so you know Danny strong is
a friend of mine he brought I worked
with him on Empire he brought this grip
to me I trusted him you know I could
work with anybody
you mean I can work with anybody because
at the end of the day I don't care who
the directory they could be new they
could be a vet once you put your soul on
it and walk away you have no control
I don't campus with a new director of
that Maya's been doing it for two years
five ten I don't know
but once I do my work and we walk away
we have no control over and after that
so it doesn't matter
you